hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and tonight I
wouldn't saw Dumbo the live-action
remake
wow that was a descriptive sound you
know I grew up with Dumbo the animated
movie and really loved it always made me
cry it's just a special original classic
film that is just really good I'm not a
fan of these remakes that they're doing
I know a lot of people aren't I know a
lot of people truly are and I think
that's awesome I think there's
definitely a market for them and an
audience for them and I'm just not in
that because I grew up with the
originals and the originals are just
better and like they're literally the
same Oh was this movie good yeah totally
was it sad did I cried yes was it like
heart-wrenching in a great way totally
but it was also super unneeded it's it's
exactly how I felt Cody and I did the
Beauty and the Beast Tamra just saw
episode and it's the same thing I
enjoyed the movie for the most part in a
way that's like I didn't need this but
it's fine and then the end kind of
redeemed it for me I would I pretty much
cosign that like it's just the same I
weigh why I wouldn't saw this in 3d
because it was the earliest showing I
could get into it's been a long day it's
why I have my fake glasses on
cuz I'm crushed me I went to a 6:30
showing of this and it was 3d and
generally 3d doesn't do it for me it's
kind of just like a bummer Vil VR but
this was actually really beautiful I
think I just haven't seen 3d in a very
long time and so it stood out as being
really pretty honestly like recommend
seeing it in 3d it was just like very
mystical the movie has like kind of like
a mystical a thrill vibe it's it's nice
it's not a word what am I thinking of
cereal cereal nailed it okay another
thing I love to cry in it's like my
favorite thing I love what a movie can
make me cry and I cry it and pretty much
anything that's gonna make you cry I cry
at I'm literally trying to create a new
show surrounding me being a big crier in
film so I literally cry to add the
trailer of this movie but that doesn't
mean that it's amazing it just means
that it's sad it means that there's sad
things happening to elephants and if you
don't cry that well then you're a
monster everything with Dumbo and Big
Mama jumbo was amazing and like really
really heartfelt and sweets and worth
watching for sure I just the character
work with such a flop in this and that's
not to say that the actors didn't do
well cuz I think that the cast is sorry
cats could you maybe pause what you're
doing I tried to film a video anyway I
think the cast was really good I think
they did a really good job I hate saying
this but I didn't love the kids I think
the kid actors weren't amazing but I
think the adults were just they were
killer I think that they were given
everything in the world though they have
this world that's already created it's
like a beloved Disney movies and for
them to not really be developed that
well was such a weird misstep he just
really it feels super safe it doesn't
feel like you get to know the characters
at all and I wanted to I liked the
snippets of fun like loving like
beautiful relationshipy stuff that you
saw was like really good and I was
craving that throughout it was really
cool it was super like I I think this is
a cool Tim Burton film
I think this had like and the good stuff
of timber
that I love and then I didn't have the
weird you know just weird unlikable Tim
Burton stuff that I've been seeing a lot
of in the past few years I know people
love those too so still opinion of mine
but this had some really cool like you
know hazy dust and cloudiness and like
magic elephants that kind of shit that I
love from Jim Burton magic elephants it
just it really lacks any kind of
character work and character design and
character development like at all like
hey really didn't care about the family
in this and I wanted to so bad like the
dad comes back from war and they have
like a hard time connecting with him the
children do and and they miss the mom
who died who there's so much juice there
and and possibility and for some reason
it just wasn't built up enough Danny
DeVito this is the second time I believe
second time that he's played I like this
ringleader circus ringleader and the
first time he did it was in my favorite
movie of all time
another Tim Burton film big fish and in
that I just I believed it so much more
it was such a better character and in
that it was characters that a lot of
people just didn't know like there it
was a book first but most people were
going into big fish kind of blind this I
don't know it had a world already and it
just for not to be built up was a weird
thing and I don't know I don't know if
it was direction or if it was writing or
acting or what it didn't seem like he
was acting it seems like he was writing
to be quite honest I think this would I
blame it on mostly it wasn't anything
Blea a direction I I just know so much
Colin Farrell was really good again I
think his character had such potential
to be built up and I think he did a
really good job in it but I think just
the writing didn't give him very much
unfortunately he's in saving mr. banks
too and I would say saving mr. banks and
this if you would even consider saving
mr. banks a remake which I wouldn't I
wouldn't so why would you but I
this is saving mr. banks have to be some
of my favorite live-action that's come
out of Disney in a while for like their
like classic Disney stuff he's cast well
in these parts I just I don't think he
was given very much at all Michael
Keaton was was really cool but he's so
much better than what he was in this if
he could have been this really cool like
mastermind bad guy and instead it was
just it was pretty bland pretty safe I
will say that's the word I want to keep
coming back to it's just it was it was
so safe and I mean sure you know you
don't really want to take Dumbo and take
it out of the box and reform it and
change it in any way because people get
mad at that but also you know it was
just it was pretty bland I did cry like
multiple times like just silently
sobbing about this elephant who doesn't
have his freaking just give him back his
mom he's got adorable stupid big ears I
love him he's the best overall that's
not enough to carry the movie I don't
think I think the CGI on the elephant on
Dumbo is really great I think he was
adorable his eyes it could just end Wars
they're just so cute but again not
enough to cover an entire movie a two
hour movie the music was absolutely
amazing really epic really beautiful I
think it all looked really cool
dreamland it was really really neat the
climax is great I I really like seeing
how Dumbo and his mom jumbo turn out and
what happens to them and then I'm just
kind of left
wanting so much from the actual humans
in this movie I think the kids are
pretty miscast I think that maybe that's
not true
because I think that the adults that I
really enjoyed I wanted more from them
so why would I
I just don't know who the kids are so
maybe that's why I'm saying that I think
I don't know the actors were not it was
just such a killer cast so I I don't
know I think they weren't given what
they needed somehow and I don't know
what that would have been it's gotta be
in the writing it really has to be in
the writing because direct orally
everything looked awesome and felt
awesome and it had a cool tone and I
know that cinematography but like you
know it just it felt like it was the
writing and the script just didn't give
them the juicy bits that you wanted and
like it was there the makings up over
there but they just they didn't they
didn't want to go too far they didn't
want to push it or change it enough and
I understand that it's a beloved one I
actually watching but that was a real
misstep I think I think it could have
been so much better was a good totally I
think I would give this six out of ten
here that was just pure thank you so
much for watching I will see you all
next week with something that doesn't
make me cry maybe who knows honestly to
be very honest
when you make it live action it makes
beasts too real and that whole she don't
a buff alliant thing becomes real
unnerving like it gets under your skin
[Music]